[Música]
m
porque si existe es porque nosotros
queríamos
porque siempre cuando preguntamos esto
pensamos como ser astronauta
doblado maestra o payaso o cualquier
cosa menos lo que somos
[Música]
y qué es
y todos
[Música]
la verdad
a todos nosotros
porque tenemos dudas e incertidumbres
y no te enteras
por qué
cómo estás
[Música]
nosotros tenemos el poder de cambiar
dice que sí
en el torno
[Música]
somos expertos
pero saben qué
[Música]
nuestro cerebro está en tren
eso quiere decir que se está poniendo
ideas
[Música]
diferente
junto con el seguro
también nosotros
también
no podemos imaginar lo podemos hacer
lo va a repetir
d
[Música]
metros
de los deportes
[Música]
direcciones
la primera vez que se puede manejar una
moto
[Música]
en el mundo
no sé
descubrir lo que quiere hacer difícil a
cualquiera como
entonces
no tenían las bases
[Música]
carrera
empezó
muchas calles de las elecciones pasan
muchos obstáculos que hacer muchísimos
ejercicios así quería quedarme
[Música]
tontas como sacrificar una adolescencia
normal
fiestas vivos desde el lado
se debe carreras
en el ambiente
y hasta la fecha todavía adelante
ah
mira
[Música]
para saber
que ha vivido y de lo que yo he
aprendido que les puedo pasar a ustedes
para que sepan que no importa el camino
que escojan si es el normal o uno
diferente al final van a estar bien
pensando en esto me llegaron tres ideas
a la mente y son tres de los más grandes
problemas a los que yo me enfrentado
hasta el día de hoy y son tres cosas que
me han hecho querer tirar la toalla pero
al grado de estar solo así y abrir los
dedos y ya hasta ahí llegó pero al mismo
tiempo son tres cosas que me han
obligado a salir adelante de una u otra
forma
el primero es no tener nadie que creyera
en mí
el segundo es no tener apoyo económico y
el tercero bueno fueron los obstáculos
ahorita les cuento cuál fue el mío
primero no tenía nadie que creer en mí
no le regresas por fin
y espérame
no tiene nada que creer en mí yo cuando
tenía 15 años ya había pasado un poco
desde la primera vez quiero subir una
moto desde ese momento yo sabía que
tenía un gran gran talento y sabía no sé
cómo pero sólo sabía que podía
pertenecer a un grupo muy selecto de las
mujeres top del motocross no sé pero era
algo que simplemente sabía y estaba raro
porque cuando volteaba mi realidad lo
único que tenía eran personas que no
creían en mí eran personas que cuando yo
me llegaba a inscribir una carrera se
reían porque era una mujer corriendo
motos o amigos que me decían literal así
me lo dijeron que tenía que haber nacido
hombre o valiente para correr motocross
o no sé entrenadores que tuve que me
dijeron que tenía que dejar de soñar que
esto no era para mí o una familia que
esté de repente me decía oye ya es
momento de madurar hay que buscar un
trabajo real o que por miedo a que yo me
lastimara como que trataban de
desalentar me un poco me acuerdo de un
día y esto no es exagerado si pasa
pues ya estaba muy cansada de siempre
estar luchando contracorriente y mago
que estaba tirado en mi alfombra sola
llorando y como que ya no tiene energía
o sea yo me sentía como un vegetal ahí
ya sin vida y no sabía cómo de dónde
agarrarme para seguir y me acuerdo que
tenía unas motos como los hot wheels por
el motos y las empresa agarrar todas y
todos mis trofeos y los guardas en cajas
y como que en ese momento dije ya o sea
ya no sé qué más hacer ya no ya no puedo
y pues no sé creo que es algo que a
todos nos ha pasado no sé a quién aquí
no ha sentido de repente que está
descargando el peso del mundo entero en
tus hombros o que pasan problemas y de
repente ya no sabemos ni ni qué hacer y
queremos como solo abandonar todo y ya
me importa y renuncio no a mí me ha
pasado miles y millones y millones de
veces y creo que me va a seguir pasando
pero al final lo que he descubierto es
que toda la fuerza que necesitamos para
seguir adelante está aquí adentro toda
esa fuerza viene de nosotros y tiene que
venir de nosotros yo en un intento de
entender que tenía mal o qué pasaba
conmigo terminé con luque fue una
psicóloga que a mí literal me salvó la
vida porque entre las cosas que me
enseñó
ahora sí estuvo eso escoge tus batallas
si vas a pelear por algo pelea por algo
que te apasione y en ese momento a mí
como que me hizo un clic o sea esta cosa
yo me di cuenta que este era mi lucha
que nadie la iba a pelear por mí y que
solo yo decidía si iba a triunfar o iba
a fracasar y que la única persona que yo
necesitaba que creyera en mí era yo
misma
entonces nada más era como agarrarte de
valor
la segunda es el apoyo económico y esta
es una de las razones por las que muchas
personas no persiguen sus sueños o se
dan por vencidos o algo queramos o no
vivimos en una sociedad de las que no
nos vemos de escapar y siempre tenemos
gastos tenemos la renta tenemos que
pagar comida necesitamos dinero
lo más fácil y yo no digo que esté mal
es estudiar una carrera tener un trabajo
que en el mejor de los casos te encanta
tener un sueldo y listo pagas tus
cuentas si vives feliz y tranquilo no
pero a veces cuando tu camino es un poco
diferente y no están establecidos eso de
tener dinero es
muy complicado yo afortunadamente cuando
empecé en las motos pues tenía mis papás
que fueron mis principales
patrocinadores ellos me compraron mis
primeras motos me llevan a mis primeras
carreras el equipo de protección pero a
medida que me fui como clavando más y
este deporte fue creciendo y se fue hace
más claro y las caídas se fueron
haciendo mucho más fuertes pues llegó un
momento en el que ya no les parecía
tanto que me estuviera lastimando y
mucho gasto para que no entonces pues
claro me hicieron retirar el apoyo y yo
como que desde una edad muy chica tuve
que como que salir al mundo y
enfrentarme a esto de buscar apoyo para
poder seguir corriendo es algo
complicado si toman en cuenta varios
factores como que soy mujer y en este
ambiente no tenía credibilidad por ser
mujer o que si yo quería ser la mejor en
este deporte pues lo que tenía que hacer
era estar entrenando todos los días todo
el día y que todo mi pensamiento y mi
mente y todo estuviera ahí y yo tiene
que salir a buscar con que seguir
corriendo y seguir compitiendo
entonces como lo he logrado o sea como
he llegado hasta el día de hoy muchos
muchos años después o como lo siguen
logrando todas estas personas que
todavía no se han muerto de hambre igual
que yo pues yo lo que pienso es con nada
te adelantaste y así con el instinto de
supervivencia muchísima muchísima
creatividad y mucha más fe así con esas
tres cosas ahora sí los obstáculos para
mí mi obstáculo más grande fue cuando
cancelaron el campeonato de motocross en
eeuu que era como mi meta más grande y
todo lo que yo soñaba imagínense que
durante más menos durante como diez años
estuve trabajando con una sola meta un
solo objetivo y durante ese tiempo todas
mis caídas mis triunfos mis éxitos mis
fracasos todas las veces que quise tirar
la toalla todos los entrenamientos este
no sé las desmañanadas todo era con ese
objetivo en el 2011 por fin todo ese
trabajo exhausto este rinde frutos y me
convierto o bueno me ganó el título de
campeona nacional de motocross
entonces yo ya estaba feliz no yo estaba
a un paso de ir en eeuu y olvidarme de
todo y hacer lo que yo quería y empecé a
hacer mi plan maestro tenía un
patrocinado en eeuu que me ofreció una
beca de trabajo que eso nadie en méxico
tenía para poder correr profesionalmente
allá con una amiga pagamos el primer mes
de renta en san diego para largarnos
irnos para allá y este yo iba a vivir
con vicky golden que es una de las
mujeres más rápidas hasta ahora entonces
eso me va a ayudar para subir muchísimo
más mi nivel y además había logrado que
una de las revistas más importantes de
motociclismo a nivel internacional me
hiciera un reportaje apenas yo llegara
ya y contará toda mi historia de cómo
había llegado y eso para mí iba a ser
buenísimo porque me va a traer
patrocinios y exposición y un man de
cosas entonces estaba súper feliz así
que ya casi me voy
no sé unas semanas antes un mes algo así
me escribe este patrocinador de eeuu en
ese hoyo perdón pero vamos a tener que
poner todo en pausa porque por alguna
razón se canceló todo el campeonato de
estado de eeuu el prof
de mujeres imagínense que ustedes han
trabajado toda su vida toda su vida
literal en una sola cosa y de repente
cuando ya estás así a punto de hacerlo
alguien te lo arrebata y no tiene esa
explicación no tiene razón y no tienes
que hacer cosas simplemente ya no está
para mí en ese momento mi vida se cayó a
pedazos y yo seguí corriendo todavía
como un año más pero llegaban las
carreras y ya ni siquiera me llenaban la
moto ya competía porque pues es lo que
ya que estaba en inercia de hacer pero
ya no tenía ninguna aspiración ya no me
podía concentrar ya no me divertía o sea
me quitaron como todo mi objetivo como
que de repente dije bueno sí y estos
diez años que me fregué muchísimo para
que no si alguien me los quito creo que
en ese momento la vida me puso a una
prueba súper grande
como que yo tenía que demostrar si de
verdad lo merecía o no si en ese momento
yo me iba a dar por vencida de vecinos
pues ya se acabó y se acabó el literal
hoy va a como a sacar algo más para
seguir y creo que todos siempre pasamos
por eso o ya hemos pasado por muchos de
esos momentos en los que de verdad dices
no o sea ya que más me puede pasar no
pero es en esos momentos más difíciles
en donde tenemos que agarrar fuerzas y
seguir adelante
howard gardner se puso a investigar la
vida de gente extraordinaria como gandhi
y picasso y descubrió que se necesitan
aproximadamente 10 años de práctica para
ser experto en algo en lo que sea no
entonces de entrada ya sabemos que es
como un camino bastante largo no primero
hay que empezar con mucha paciencia
esa fue mi segunda oportunidad de
repente unos meses después una amiga me
invitó a correr downhill qué es eso y
encontré en un nuevo deporte todo lo que
tenía en la moto pero con nuevos retos y
nuevas cosas que aprender y de repente
volví a nacer encontré lo que me hacía
falta y de ahí pues para adelante no fue
cómo enseñar esa
esa perseverancia algo que a mí me ha
servido mucho y que les quiero compartir
y que he aprendido durante estos 10 años
que aún me falta mucho por aprender pero
al menos ya llevo estos 10 años primeros
de práctica es esto esta frase me llegó
un día de la nada a la cabeza y se me
quedó pegada porque representa para mí
todo en lo que yo creo es voy a explicar
el corazón volando para mí eso quiere
decir cómo entrar en sintonía con tu ser
y escucharte a ti mismo y dejar que tu
corazón vuele libre y vuele alto y te
marque el camino que desde seguir él te
va a decir que te gusta que no te gusta
y sólo escucharlo la segunda parte es no
le pasaron otra vez los pies andando y
esa parte para mí representa pues seguir
tu corazón escucharte y cuando entras en
sintonía tomar acción y seguir adelante
y nunca parar yo mucho tiempo estuve
como luchando con estas luces que me
decían que no podía y con este deber ser
o querer ser y caí en esta vida de un
trabajo normal y un horario normal pero
la verdad es que no era para mí de
repente me puse
a tomar la decisión y ahora seguir el
camino que todos y en ese asilo escogía
tenía que olvidarme de los deportes o
seguir mi propio camino y dejar de
perder tiempo yo escogí mi propio camino
y lo que les puedo decir es que no es
fácil da miedo es como aventarte al
vacío y esperar caer en blandito pero lo
primero que tienen que hacer es
aceptarlo aceptar que van a seguir su
propio camino sea el que sea puede ser
normal o normal segundo tomar
responsabilidad de él y tercero alejarse
de todo lo que los aleje de eso entonces
bueno con eso yo empiezo a tomar varias
acciones éste sabía que tenía un talento
pero que de las carreras no iba a vivir
así que me empecé a hacer como una marca
empecé a cuidar mi imagen me convertí en
mi diseñador en mi patrocinador en mi
buscador de patrocinios en mi
representante y por otro lado en el lado
del rendimiento busque un equipo y lo
armé yo sola de entrenadores y de
psicólogos que me ayudaran a todavía
mejorar mucho más mi nivel he logrado
muchas cosas pero quiero lograr
muchísimas más entonces empecé a hacer
esas dos cosas y creo que cada uno de
nosotros en lo que hagamos tenemos que
buscar como esas acciones y esos caminos
que nos van a llegar a un objetivo mucho
más grande no nos cerramos las puertas y
yo los quiero dejar con una interrogante
o una pregunta ustedes qué camino van a
seguir cuál es su camino y qué acciones
van a tomar para acercarse cada vez más
a su objetivo y sobre todo algo muy
importante como su talento va a ayudar a
otras personas puede ser un empresario y
tienes la capacidad de hacer tu empresa
la más grande pero también tienes la
capacidad de hacer que tus trabajadores
sean felices en tu empresa si tienes un
restaurante llénalo de gente que hagan
colas y colas y colas esperando
asentarse pero nunca dejes que alguien
se vaya sin una sonrisa en la boca o en
la cara y yo yo soy una campeona no solo
para llenarme de medallas sino para
enseñarle a las personas que a pesar de
todos los obstáculos y todas las dudas
al final puedes llegar al éxito en lo
que te gusta
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]